d ce congrès coïncide avec les
célébrations du 30e anniversaire de la
mort de che guevara resté dans la
mémoire des cubains comme le héros
mythique de la révolution anti
impérialiste comme on disait à l'époque
à cuba ce n'est pas le portrait de filet
le casse prouve que l'on trouve à chaque
coin de rue mais celui de che guevara
thierry thulliez jean françois renaud
numéro un du classement car à pattes et
tout le monde a son et du corps mais
maintenant nous allons chanter l'hymne
de l'ayrolle le visage hideux que yom a
pas onze en les touchant d'une même voix
hymne à la gloire du guérillero che
guevara l'école à cuba ça commence
toujours comme ça pas une journée sans
slogan duce
mais ce 8 octobre être particulier le
che est tombé sous les balles des
soldats boliviens il ya tout juste
trente ans ces ossements découverts dans
une fosse commune en bolivie ont été
transférés à la havane et cuba se
prépare à de grandioses funérailles
officielles
alors aujourd'hui dans cette école
primaire de la banlieue de la havane
la direction a demandé aux élèves de
rivaliser en ferveur révolutionnaire
je sens qu'un de chaîner de chaque
particule et celui là vous voyez vous ne
pourrez pas le tuer préparez-vous à la
lutte parce que le tce n'est pas mort
vive le check in et chaque jour dans la
serra allons lutter cendres guerrière
dans cette école dite du guérillero
héroïque
on se rappelle que le tce fut l'un des
artisans de l'alphabétisation un des
êtres de la révolution
le che est partout des murs ou manuel
rien ne manque à la légende relayé par
tous les professeurs cet homme même s'il
écoute large au coeur d'une dimension
tout à fait universel qu'elle fasse car
il a participé au mouvement
révolutionnaire dans toute l'amérique
pouvez vous le dire mais c'est que nous
commémorons le 8 octobre
patricia est est ce que le 30e
anniversaire de la mort au combat du
guérillero héroïque et de ses compagnons
que viens pratique puisqu'il a fallu le
régime tandis que se perpétue et depuis
plus de 30 ans en transmettant un
message révolutionnaire simple la patrie
ou la mort auquel à cuba tout est soumis
l'économie comme les libertés publiques